olá gente boa tarde
meu nome é henrique busco trazer para
vocês um pouco do que eu acredito que
houve nesses últimos anos
bom para poder começar a contextualizar
a minha história eu quero que vocês
imaginem que aqui tem uma porta é fácil
porque vocês quiserem madeira metal
eu saí dessa porta agora sabe que eu
acabei de fazer eu me assumi eu sou gay
e é com isso que eu quero trazer para
vocês a minha história toda essa cultura
que aprendi essa visão de diversidade
que eu tenho para falar um pouquinho
mais essa história eu dar um passo para
trás quando tinha 22 anos de idade teve
um louco que me colocou como gestor de
400 pessoas
se eu tivesse a consciência que eu tenho
hoje acho que teria sido um pouco mais
fácil mas tudo bem sobrevivido aqui
também obrigado
naquele período eu descobri que a
diversidade é linda e ela existia eram
400 características diferentes
eram 400 pessoas pedindo e fazendo
coisas sonhos desejos dificuldades e
para me aproximar delas
contextualizando um pouquinho mais era
um dos mais novos têm respeito é mais
difícil mas vamos lá comecei a me
aproximar deles e um dos caminhos que eu
fiz foi criar empatia respeita a
conversar e dar opiniões como eu fiz
isso
nós temos várias atividades eu tinha que
ler alguma coisa xis aqui eu trazia um
grupo e falar a gente me ajuda e o que
eles falavam era importante ele tinha
uma outra atividade aqui que eu
precisava
a gente precisa de ajuda que também eu
trazia equipe para falar aqui comigo
para construir aqui foi um mundo é
ferver sente esse período a gente vendeu
como nunca fizemos várias ações
interessantes
sabe por que isso aconteceu porque houve
respeito com o passar dos anos eu fui
aprendendo um pouco mais sobre esse tema
vim para são paulo percebi que a
diversidade é que era um pouquinho mais
diversa nossa descobriu um monte de
cultura
descobri um monte de gente de origem
diferente onde crença diferente e é
muito legal conversar com essas pessoas
e botar numa mesma sala e você perceber
que um tema que eles estão que nós nos
propusemos a conversar
se você perguntar diferente ou a mesma
pergunta e é bom ter resposta diferente
e cada um deles
essa é a parte legal da diversidade essa
é a parte legal que a gente tem que
colocar dentro das empresas
essa é a parte legal que a gente tem que
fazer ser promovido
nesses anos todos que eu estou em são
paulo teve passagem por algumas empresas
e foi muito interessante chegar em uma
delas e ver profissionais bons
a exemplo de uma mulher quer uma
excelente profissional mas estava
estacionada estava parado ali no canto
era ótima na lista
só que ninguém percebeu o potencial que
ela tinha para ser gerente
vem cá vamos conversar e se entender
qual é o seu problema deixou entender
aonde nós estamos errando e sabe que
estava errado não era ela era a
oportunidade que está sendo dada
ela era [ __ ]
foram três anos trabalhando como eu saí
da empresa a gerente
ela já era coordenador antes uma prova
foi promovido na minha área
sabe o que eu fiz uma simples coisa
respeitar a capacidade produtiva dela
falta amor falta respeito essas pessoas
têm o que falar
essas pessoas tenham que dizer essas
pessoas têm que colaborar em outras
empresas tive profissionais a exemplo de
um outro caso um negro quer um excelente
vendedor [ __ ] também só que uma
autoestima
um pouco apagada diminuída pelos anos de
não essa reunião você não precisa e não
deixa que eu vou nessa reunião não fique
tranquilo só prepara um documento para
ser enviado
só que aconteceu nesses anos todos ele
foi deixado de lado
sabe o que aconteceu quando eu cheguei
para trabalhar com ele
ele virou simplesmente o melhor vendedor
da empresa durante um ano
eu não fiz nada diferente eu dei força
a gente precisa fazer isso a gente
precisa dar voz a essas pessoas
a gente precisa entender que a
diversidade é algo sério tá na cara de
todo mundo
só que a gente não vê olham para o lado
de vocês está aqui e não faço a
diversidade lgbt negros pessoas com
deficiências pessoas mas sim menos
diversidade em sua totalidade
pessoas que estão fugindo dos seus
países por causa da guerra e que chegam
nos países de destino e não são
recebidos é um ser humano
ninguém sabe a dor que essa pessoa
passou
nós temos que respeitar mas temos que
acolher e tem gente chegando às empresas
eu tive um exemplo disso algumas semanas
atrás para entrevistar um profissional
que era de vindo sim de um país do
oriente médio fugido
ele tinha trabalhado em uma empresa que
a empresa parecida com a mesma linha no
mesmo segmento daquele país
só quando a gente começou a conversar
ele não tinha muito bem desenvolvido
português e me pediram para não seguir
com esse contratação da empresa minha
empresa ela está apoiando a minha
empresa nós estamos destravando a eu fui
conversar com as pessoas que estão
tocando na empresa e seguimos com o
processo o que eu quero dizer para vocês
é que se nós não tomarmos a atitude de
executar não vai acontecer
olhem para as empresas de vocês briguem
com respeito
trago essa falta à tona promovam essa
conversa com quem já está dentro e com
quem estava entrando
eu vou trazer um caso pra vocês
hipotético
imagine que nós temos um segmento de
moda nesse segmento nós vamos atender
todo o brasil
nós temos que construir um produto que
ele deve ser desdobrado em vários
segmentos beach o cib e eu tenho dois
tipos de equipe
o primeiro aqui o primeiro tipo de
equipe são pessoas muito bem graduadas
tiveram oportunidades nas melhores
escolas de capitais importantes do país
pós graduação nas universidades top
alguns fizeram intercâmbio
imagino que se eu poderia falar um
pouquinho do que eles fizeram durante as
férias na infância com quase toda
certeza eles fizeram uma viagem em julho
para a disney
depois de passar 15 dias em nova york
alguns ainda foram para miami trouxeram
jaqueta questionam daquela marca
vocês devem lembrar que eu quero dizer
para vocês é que o mesmo chama o mesmo
essa equipe aqui
tecnicamente ela existe
vamos falar um pouquinho dessa outra
equipe considerando que nós estamos
fazendo a mesma atividade produzindo
mesmo produto para o mesmo segmento e
com as mesmas responsabilidades nessa
equipe tem uma mulher que a nossa chapa
dó ela tem 60 anos de idade está quase
aposentando é mãe de quatro filhos
acabou de ser avó é uma experiência como
ninguém
ela não está tão rápido agora já foi um
dia
mas toda vez que ela participa de uma
conversa ela nos traz histórias
ela sabe como é que a empresa se
movimentou nesses últimos anos a empresa
tem marca né
a marca tem vida
tem história é importante saber nessa
mesma equipe de uma garota transgênero
ela veio de minas tem dois anos que ela
operou encontrou alegria
ela estudou em paris e passou um período
em nova york fazendo uma pós-graduação
nessa mesma equipe tem um filho de
fazendeiro do mato grosso do sul que
sempre morou na fazenda estudar na
cidade mais próxima
coincidências ou não lá tinham faculdade
ele se graduou e veio para são paulo 11
passando um processo de trainee da nossa
empresa um caso hipotético também tem
uma menina que veio do sul
os avós dela vieram da guerra européia
fugidos
ela estudou grato veio para são paulo e
mora sozinha é jovem tem também um novo
destino
foi com a mãe fugir da separação que ela
teve com o pai ele não teve muita
condições de estudo mas chegou em são
paulo trabalhava em dois empregos e
estudava à noite se graduou e é um dos
mais jovens da equipe também está
crescendo tem potencial tem brilho nos
olhos e por último veio de manaus na
semana passada ele é descendente de
índios
eu nunca tinha conversado com alguém que
desse dinheiro pode dizer que esses dois
clubes agora tem desenvolver um produto
teoricamente a gente quer desenvolver o
mesmo produto
qual das duas consciências pensar em
produtos mais diversos
vamos considerar também que eles podem
contratar uma consultoria
eles contratam essa consultoria eu
espero também que eles sejam diversos
mas se não forem normalmente não são
a gente está falando quase igual ao do
mesmo aqui a mesma consultoria sido
contratada por mais que eles tenham uma
igualdade de personalidades consciência
e tudo mais
até o briefing dessa equipe presta
consultoria
é diferente eles também vão contatar uma
agência agência de ambiente mais
diversificado mais tranquila um
eles falam pra caramba mas eles recebem
um briefing com cabeças diferentes do
desdobramento resultado também é
diferente
eu quero dizer para vocês gente que nós
estamos em 2018 é feio chegar aqui e
temos que falar que temos que olhar para
as diferenças
eu tenho vergonha é por isso que a
disputa coloca essa pauta na minha boca
pra dizer para as pessoas que se a gente
não mudar isso agora vai chegar a 2020 e
2050 ea gente vai estar fazendo a mesma
coisa
discutindo a mesma pauta é uma vergonha
nós seres humanos precisamos nos
movimentar visando gerar mais
consciência
precisamos sair dessa mesmice gente
o mercado de um ano atrás não é o mesmo
de significado desse ano o mercado que
vocês trabalharam daqui a um ano dois
anos não vai ser o mesmo se você estiver
pensando com a mesma consciência é
melhor você sair da empresa e fazer
outra coisa porque você estava errando
vai ver alguém vai atropelar a empresa
de vocês pensem diferente
busque a diferença quando construiu essa
palestra eu disse que não ia militar
mas depois eu disse eu vou eu preciso
falar um pouco sobre isso
essas pessoas têm direitos
essas pessoas precisam ser escutadas
autoestima dessas pessoas precisa ser
valorizado
essas pessoas têm conhecimento e não
estão sendo executadas as empresas
precisam investir nessas pessoas de
forma diferente se não de forma igual
colocar todo mundo no mesmo canto
ensinar a mesma coisa pra todo mundo
nem todos tiveram a mesma capacidade a
mesma sorte
precisamos trazer gente com outras
consciências para um nível de gestão e
se isso não acontecer a gente tem ano
não acontecer mas vai continuar na mesma
essas pessoas têm direito eu tenho
direito
eu quero usá los
eu vou parar de medida não era o foco
mas é importante deixar um pouco
contextualizando quando me propus fazer
essa palestra pra cá eu pensei eu quero
falar um pouco do que está efervescente
nas empresas e que algumas já começaram
a falar e que algumas já começaram a
desenvolver
eu tenho orgulho de dizer que a minha
está fazendo isso eu tenho orgulho de
olhar para as pessoas que estão se
predispondo a executar isso e ver que
cada vez mais elas estão sentindo à
vontade
existem pesquisas uma delas foi a 15 que
dizem que empresas que têm na liderança
pessoas mais diversificadas coloridas
abertas diferentes
essas empresas podem chegar até o lucro
até 30% maior
eles estudaram mil empresas em 12 países
se vocês quiserem mais dados tem um
monte de coisa na internet e tem um
monte de gente dizendo sobre isso e eu
quero que cada vez mais se fala sobre
isso para que nós tenhamos sim uma
movimentação da nossa vontade de liderar
essa diferença essa alteração e essas
mudanças nas nossas cadeiras se vocês
contratarem pessoas olhem e busca
indicações de colegas de vocês de
pessoas que têm um pouco de diferença um
pouco de conhecimento diversificando
para poder agregar na área de vocês vão
voltar para aquele caso hipotético
quantos desses aqui viveram parte da
vida desse grupo
quantos desses aqui tiveram uma
oportunidade desenvolver um produto com
consciência para o meio agrícola lembra
que tinha um filho de fazendeiro
quantos desses aqui poderiam falar sobre
produtos para a comunidade lgbt
talvez
mas será que aqui não tem um pouco mais
de consciência quanto destaque poderiam
falar um pouco mais um produto da
terceira idade lembra o nosso xodó é
disso que eu falo militar importante as
pessoas que fazem isso tem o meu
respeito mas pensar fora também e não só
militar que colocar isso dentro da
empresa porque da empresa não se milita
dentro da empresa se conquista
eu vou dar uma dica pra vocês conquistar
isso se usa respeito atenção carinho e
escuta
às vezes fala porque uma uma fala
conforta
se vocês verem alguém da equipe de vocês
colega de vocês que precisam desse apoio
estendam a mão
saiba que você está ajudando mais do que
vocês imaginam porque as dificuldades
dessas pessoas
só elas sabem e para terminar
eu quero fazer uma pergunta pra vocês
depois de tudo isso que contextualizar e
acreditando que mais diversidade é mais
criatividade e produtividade
a minha pergunta pra vocês é a próxima
vez que vocês fizeram uma contratação
que vocês escolheram muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]